okay
so you spoke
of the shift from
objective to subjective
so
to possibility
so we have this obsession or this focus
on the object
and
one could say that um the entire
spiritual journey basically begins with
shifting from
focus or attention or perception on the
object to like the very line of
perception itself
and then to the very subject or the
perceiver
so
nice that that is sort of like the main
part you could say of of the initial
part of the spiritual journey is that
um and then when you shift to the
subject
and you recognize that
um
the subject is actually
the one infinite creator it's actually
god
and
that's the same thing that's looking out
of your eyes
and out of everyone's eyes
and
so then
you realize that there's like an
eternity or an infinity to your
beingness
and that you can sort of relax your
obsession with being the body and relax
your obsession with being the thoughts
and relax your obsession with objects
and focus more on the possibilities like
you said
and
this is what
i wrote in high level perception that
first book that i wrote that you're
checking out and chapter two is called
seed theory
yeah
and so in seed theory
you have
basically a
analogy that you're drawing between
the tree of possibility from the seed
and all of the possibilities that branch
hey one sec actually atlas i don't mean
to cut you off but i think it would be
powerful if you shared screen if you
have it pulled up there you could share
screen and you can click on it because i
see the illustration that you're talking
about in front of me or if you make me a
co-host i can share my screen for you
i think showing them
i just love how on point you are because
uh that's gonna make it so much better
for sure you know what i mean
yeah
okay here we go
boom
sweet so that's chapter four go to
chapter two
okay
oh you're right that is chapter four
okay
see theory right here well it's like a
map
nice
sweet
so
um
okay
so
if
if you tune into possibilities above
everything and you recognize that
everything that's objective
is downstream
of what is subjective of what is
the focus or the imagination or the will
or the creativity of god of the one
infinite creator so
then you feel more and more okay
so why don't i tune into that seed level
the possibility space and i make this
analogy with the tree
and i see that out of all of my like
possible trajectories in life
that i can persistently
constantly focus on and choose my
preferred state and my preferred
frequency which is oneness shambhala
service coming from there and also
seeing in that north star position
igniting global awakening the mission
architecting shambhalas across the
planet and nothing being higher than
that and so then
your
all of your focus
in imagination is on that
and as god as the one infinite creator
with the stylus painting
and so then guess what happens is within
five years 10 years 15 years this entire
planet is saturated with spiritual
kingdoms and then guess what happens is
somebody 15 years later
turns and asks themselves hey
how did this all happen how did the
subject or the imagination become object
of shambhala's across earth
and this is how it happened because we
focused on the possibility space we
focused on the root the root or the
substratum is the fact that you are god
you are the one infinite creator you
have the [ __ ] stylus in your
imagination and so
we manifest
the external and so
focusing on the possibility space is so
critical and also focusing
simultaneously on the seed level of
basic needs being met is what enables
people from around the world to be able
to have clean drinking water and have
food and have shelter and not have
diseases
and just have energy and abundance so
that they themselves can also turn
inward and ask themselves the question
who am i what is i what is my nature and
also get through any layers of
separation or lack or location or these
types of things and then it becomes
easier for us to prosper as a planet so
the basic needs which you could say are
the physicality
actually fuel the subjective as well so
they're in a feedback loop with each
other the subjective and the objective
so that's why it's so important to have
the simultaneity of both
yes yeah